make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys to the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're gonna be covering x-men
later on this week kind of getting back
into the swing of things or at least as
best we can without there being any real
new comic releases I think they're like
Marvel and DC or doing some digital
stuff but much like the rest of us
Marvel and DC are just kind of flying by
the seat of their pants in terms of how
all this is gonna how this is gonna work
and all that kind of stuff
this really is an unprecedented
situation but what we have here at least
what we're gonna do and you know and
today we're gonna cover of course Ultron
forever now Ultron forever is kind of an
unofficial sequel and not really even a
sequel kind of a spiritual successor to
a story called Avengers Forever and
Avengers forever was an old-school story
not really super old-school but like a
turn-of-the-century
story from from Marvel they're really
focused on the idea of Avengers from
like different points in time all coming
together to fight a fight a particular
foe but what this does is it basically
picks up at some point in the future now
it simply says the year is 2000 and
something or other right we're not given
a definitive date but what you have here
is the golden skull which basically kind
of seems to be a sort of successor to
the red school but obviously some kind
of a super criminal here now what we're
met with is this versions or this this
timelines version of Captain America
which is actually a chick named named
Danny Cage now we'll find out you know
that here in a little bit for right now
we can kind of throw it out there it's
not a major focal point but of course
basically I mean she goes as far as to
say like you know my father's Luke Cage
my mother's Jessica Jones now Danny Cage
is kind of an interesting character
because she's been depicted in different
ways over the years if I recall
correctly she did appear during the
events of old man Logan this is one of
the more interesting roles where she
became the new Captain America now how
that happened we're not explicitly told
here there is a story out there that I
believe focuses explicitly on her origin
somewhere in Marvel Comics but it's
actually kind of interesting right it's
just a future version of that character
which is always sort of cool now these
photos are taken out quite readily and
as soon as she goes in for you know to
take out the golden skull then suddenly
she's whisked away and that's really
kind of a common theme that we're gonna
see going on here that you've got
Avengers Tower and you know and at least
in the present day as it's given to us
but you've basically got you know black
widow kind of doing her thing hanging
out with vision and so on and really
just the two of them kind of engaging in
a training situation a training
simulation but much like Captain America
in the future you know Danny Cage
they're whisked away as well only for us
to find out the person who did this is
Doctor Doom now those are guys who are
exceedingly familiar with Marvel
you probably immediately like I did you
looked at that that rectangle-shaped box
that was basically taking them away and
immediately saw it as dr. Doom's time
platform right in Marvel Comics those
are guys who don't know Doctor Doom has
mastered the ability to travel through
time the issue is that time is one of
these things where the smarter you are
the more you understand how you
shouldn't screw with it right that's the
reason why Wolverine who's kind of an
idiot started messing with time and
screwing things up during age of Ultron
because he's just kind of a he's kind of
a goof in a lot of different ways right
he just kind of goes in guns blazing
that kind of a thing whereas Reed
Richards was kinda like we can't screw
with time and that's really why dr. doom
doesn't use the time platform all that
often he's let me never use it a few
times over the course of Marvel because
going back and changing time for which
spiral out a litany of alternate
realities right in the future would say
the same so it's one of these things
where like like with Days of Future past
is a really good example that with Days
of Future past the idea was okay we're
gonna go back in time we're gonna stop
the assassination of Charles Xavier
Morra McTaggart and Senator Robert
Kelley and and basically prevent the
future where the Sentinels conquered
everything but the issue is that because
they came from that future
you can't come from a place that doesn't
exist right so that future has to exist
the result is that you know they're they
essentially created a new timeline where
Days of Future past never happened
that's kind of the issue that you run
into you when you when you talk about
manipulating time and marwah comics but
ultimately what Doctor Doom is done is
he's brought together Avengers from
different time periods you guys will
probably recognize James Rhodes as Iron
Man he was Iron Man at one point way
back in the 80s of course we've got
Danny Cage who comes from the future the
funny thing is the Incredible Hulk as
you see him here is actually before the
Avengers were founded right so this is
way back essentially the original
Incredible Hulk and then of course a lot
of the guys will recognize Jane Foster
Thor now the funny thing about this is
that this story being written in 2015
basically coincides with the time when
Jane Foster became Thor in Marvel Comics
and we got one of the best store runs of
all time in the sense that like original
sin in 2014 was basically Thor losing
the ability to wield his hammer right
and that's kind of the funny thing that
goes on here is because as soon as they
basically realized this is Doctor Doom
they immediately attack now in the
middle of fighting him suddenly you have
these kids and this guy America kinda
kind of comes running out of nowhere
and then was sort of like okay there are
kids who are running to the to the to
the aid of Doctor Doom what is going on
here and so once the body kind of begins
to calm down then what you get here is
really
kind of meet-and-greet from these
various Avengers who were here and so of
course you have you know vision you have
Incredible Hulk you have these folks
meeting each other Danny Cage introduces
herself to to a Tasha Romanoff basically
saying like I know you are we've fought
alongside each other for quite some time
patashu Romanoff is like yeah I know who
you are but like you're six months old
and then you have the meeting between
thor odin's son and jane foster now
here's that here's the cool thing we're
actually gonna see a kind of a kind of
nod to this later on but it's one of
these funny things where like initially
this kind of discussion on like the
death of Thor or you know the death of
Odin's son or something along those
lines and ultimately you know that the
kind of discussion here is basically
agreed that it's some point along the
line
Odin son passes the hammer to somebody
else now the funny thing about this is
Odin son assumes that he passes the
mantle on right there like you know
something happens to Odin that Odin
never recovers from the Odin sleep or
something like that then he dies and
Thor basically says okay I'll take the
place of Odin and then basically says
like we need a new Thor and then
somebody else has chosen to be that
person Odin son you know because he's
from the past does not know that he's
going to lose his ability to wield his
hammer and that's what's kind of cool
about all this you know if you get this
really really cool nod later on but
essentially with everybody kind of
coming together and saying okay you know
like like saner heads are prevailing dr.
doom tell us what the world is going on
but essentially dr. doom starts talking
to everybody and basically saying at
some point along the line Ultron
basically rose to power now here's the
funny thing about this Ultron
essentially returns and managed to kill
all the superheroes but one of the super
superheroes who is dead is star brand
now the reason why Al Ewing has done
this is because at the time when this
story was written the full totality and
the nature of star brand had not fully
been explored by Marvel Comics yet it
hadn't been explored by Jonathan Hickman
at this point in time star brand was
just kind of already there and we were
getting to the closing act of Avengers
and new Avengers now if you guys recall
once you got to the closing act once you
got to the final act and you had the
battle between hyper oh yeah I guess
Hyperion Odin Sun star brand Knight mask
and then and then the beyonders that's
when you got the full explanation that
Kevin as star Brandt has as much power
as he needs to face off against whatever
threat he's going to be fighting at the
time this was written that wasn't the
case we didn't know if that was the case
and so the result is that you basically
just kind of had okay you know star
brand essentially shows up here star
brain was taken out just like everybody
else because they haven't been
established that he had an infinite
amount of power that if Ultron shows up
he could take
I'm out but there's also other scenarios
that are being implemented here right
we're basically told this is the
ultimate version of Ultron Ultron
already had an adamantium shell right so
far brand power is more of kind of drunk
force right he's not really a reality
manipulator he's not like Franklin
Richards right it's just enough power to
destroy a particular thing but
adamantium cannot truly be destroyed in
Marvel Comics because it's essentially
the most durable metal in all of
existence and so aside from like being
able to break it down on the molecular
level using something like anti metal
vibranium or using reality warping
abilities to control the atomic
structure of matter there probably
wasn't really a way for star bland to
destroy Ultron in the first place
something else funny that you see here
down in the very bottom right hand left
hand corner you see Robocop but what we
end up learning here is it essentially
what had happened is that after Ultron
had destroyed the entirety of the
superhero community every single
superhero on earth did following that he
in turn basically went through and
started creating like this just litany
of Ultron robots right so it's very akin
to like age of Ultron meets like
Terminator with Skynet just like
spawning an army of terminators to take
out what was left of humanity the
difference here is that much like the
Sentinels from Days of Future past with
Ultron it was overwhelming force Ultron
was way beyond the Sentinels right just
in terms of capabilities and whatnot
like a singular Ultron could have
destroys all the Sentinels during Days
of Future past
he's exceedingly capable here but after
that what he ended up doing is after
creating all these different Ultron
robots I kind of solidify his reign that
those individuals who rebelled those
members of the superhero community who
didn't die in the original skirmish and
were discovered to have survived by some
strange means in turn they basically
tried to overthrow Ultron and they were
basically brainwashed right their minds
were completely wiped and in turn they
became servants of Ultron himself this
basically happened across the board with
humanity right like he-man and
themselves only about thirty million
people left on earth and all of them are
servants of Ultron so there really is no
free will that exists anymore what he's
also done is he's kind of created these
sort of androids right artificial
intelligence organisms which he refers
to as as Avengers and actually uses the
weapons of the original Avengers which
is kind of a crazy thing to see but what
Doctor Doom is basically done is sat
down it kind of created this sort of a
method to ultimately defeat Ultron by
analyzing him by looking at him and
realizing the shortcomings of himself
that Ultron has essentially left himself
open when the
gets together and they kind of start
talking and saying okay what's your plan
dr. doom basically says well one of the
big failings of Ultron is that he is
still very much human in terms of his
thinking the funny thing about this
story is that this tied into Avengers
number 31 right we saw this future
during Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers we only saw a glimpse of it
but we saw a future where like Ultron
had conquered everything but what you
ended up having here is basically Doctor
Doom kind of creating this multifaceted
plan the first one is to basically it's
what the Avengers really into two three
main teams the first team of Iron Man
and vision will basically launch a
frontal assault on what was Avengers
mansion and is now in the main base of
operations for Ultron and of course you
know as they make their way in it's
kinda like okay they're gonna be the
main frontal assault they're gonna focus
on on this and basically draw the
attention of the various Avengers who
were there the problem with this is that
once they launch their attack they're
immediately overwhelmed right just like
that they're taken out with a quickness
literally James Rhodes gets shot in his
chest device and that basically ends up
you know powering down his entire suit
of armor like shutting the whole thing
down
ah then you've got vision who's
basically overtaken by his by himself by
his future self as he seems to have been
manipulated or at least controlled by
Ultron and then you end up switching to
two the second team and the second team
was more of a strike team right it was
kind of it was falling in line really
more with the nature of Black Widow kind
of a black op strike team this idea that
Ultron would essentially have two main
systems right he would have a backup
system and then he would have like the
main system they can take down the
entire basis behind this backup system
is to basically end up rallying troops
right that with Ultron's you know kind
of as he calls it the World Wide Web but
basically a system that broadcasts
messages of obedience and control
through the the various headsets of
those humans who were controlled by
Ultron and that destroying the backup
system and then destroying the main
system will take away Ultron's ability
to maintain his control over the 30
million humans who were left what this
means is that these individuals can be
either imbued with powers or can be
given weapons and arms and armament and
can basically wage war against Ultron
now at this point I would say it
wouldn't even really matter there's so
many Ultron robots you wouldn't really
think they would have a chance anyway
right like what are 30 million baseline
humans with some weapons and like a
handful of superheroes like against 30
million Ultron robots right like it
would be more than enough to wipe out
everybody here like you'd even cut that
number by a 30th right and say like a
million Ultron robots is enough to
annihilate the rest of humanity and all
the superheroes who were here right
really all you need and so once they
basically end up getting into this
facility you end up having like this
this future version of Black Widow
facing off against all of them along
with a whole bunch of human servants now
the idea is not to kill the human
servants but to take out black widow and
one of the other things we end up
learning here which is really really
cool is that you basically have Captain
America she uses a thought-controlled
shield that her her shield is
anti-gravity and it's it's controlled by
her thoughts as opposed to Captain
America's shield which was just pure
vibranium and was literally just
ricocheted right it was just ricochet
and then bouncing back that kind of a
thing but what is up happening here is
that while this is a cool weapon in
terms of its design that basically this
future version of Black Widow hijacks
the thought patterns of the shield and
then takes it under her control throws
of The Incredible Hulk and decapitates
the Hulk and so finally you know with
this this team essentially looking like
they're falling quite readily right
falling with a quickness though what we
end up doing is basically jumping to
both Thor's and as they make their way
to the to the main base of operations
they end up passing through the bog to
the Bifrost bridge two Ultron's seat of
power and where Jane Foster initially
kind of looks at this it says okay so
like this is a copy of the Rainbow
Bridge and this is crazy he's basically
kind of rebuilt a scar for himself the
Ultron controlled Thor jumps into the
fray and basically says no none of this
is what you think it is the funny thing
about this odin son is that you look at
this this future version of yourself
this future Thor and I imagine that you
probably believe that like you pass the
mantle on through some kind of death and
glorious combat that you die a hero's
death or you rise to become the new
ruler of Asgard to replace Odin but
there's some measure of honor you end up
passing the mantle on that's not true
you fall that's all that happens you
fall this future version of Thor
basically tells us what happened in
original sin that Odin son lost his
worthiness he lost the ability to wield
his hammer and the hammer in turn passed
on to Jane Foster right so it's a cool
thing to see because what he basically
says is like I'm gonna let you in on a
little bit of a secret right I do this
and I enjoy doing this right there is a
greater truth to all of this isn't it
that's that's going on I do all this in
service to the throne of Asgard and I do
it gladly right because my mission is to
serve the all-father and the all-father
the person who killed Odin and took over
Asgard is actually none other than
Ultron prime himself
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with Ultron forever right so in the
first video we covered this idea that it
really kind of took place in an
alternate reality that was kind of
introduced during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers but what you
ended up having here was this situation
where Ultron had managed to conquer a
portion or at least conquer the earth at
some point in the future so it made it
very similar to the events of the age of
Ultron story the difference here is that
Doctor Doom in this time period seems to
exist and basically secure the Avengers
from different points in time in order
to bring them to a singer' location and
have them all faceoff right and so what
this does is it picks up with Thor from
the past as well as Jane Foster from
seemingly the present day at the time
this story was written facing off
against their version of Thor from the
future right this version of Thor that
operates as a servant of sorts to Ultron
now the funny thing about this is that
when when Ultron Thor will call him that
will call him Ultron Thor when Ultron
Thor faces off against Odin's son he
initially gets the upper hand quite
readily and then actually delivers a
killing blow the issue here is that
Odin's son doesn't die now this goes all
the way back to the events of Walt
Simonson's run on four and in fact we're
officially and even even a Ewing
actually makes him note of this that
it's in Thor 373 it actually goes back
to issues 361 and 362 and the reason why
is because following his death at the
hands of man got the idea of Thor was to
go to the afterlife to the realm of
Halle secure the soul of Odin and bring
it you know bring it back or at the very
least get it to Valhalla the issue with
this is that over time and over the
course that story because of the fact
that Thor had so brazenly invaded her
realm hella essentially cursed for in
the sense that he would basically be
immortal but his body would begin to
erode away right so he would experience
all the pains that come with with
mortality that come with aging right his
body would get old his body would
eventually shrivel up his bones would
get brittle different things like that
he wouldn't stay youthful for all
eternity but he would never be able to
die right and so it's actually probably
a fate worse than death to be honest and
that's what's kind of going on here in
this moment right now Thor you know
Odin's son is effectively immortal and
that's what that's really the one thing
that saves them here because in response
to that you know he basically ends up
using his power and handling it directly
into Ultron Thor and then of course Jane
Foster does the same thing and what this
does is it overloads Ultron Thor he
starts speaking in machine language and
then essentially a kind of AI comes
popping out now when I was when I was
reading this I was actually thinking
about making a joke
cuz I was like well it's not really Loki
it's younglings Thor speaking of
younglings
anything I've ever had Ying Ying's
before you guys know exactly what I'm
talking about but nonetheless you know
this basically is it's kind of an AI up
form of Loki now here's that here's the
issue at this and this is one of the on
running themes that we're gonna run into
you when it comes to Ultron forever is
that there are a lot of cool things that
happen here but there's not really much
explanation as to how it got that way
the only real exception is what we're
gonna find out with regards to the
Asgardians but as far as Loki the only
real indication were given here is that
Loki's obsession with humanity with with
Midgard and especially Midgard
technology somehow seems to have led to
him becoming a kind of artificial
intelligence and this artificial
intelligence was taken by Ultron and
basically imbued into Thor and that's
how he's been controlling Thor the
entire time now on one side we can kind
of look at this and believe that it's
not actually Loki but on the other hand
we're basically told that it is right
that it really is Loki this is the
current form he's in now and he may
evolve from there something along those
lines but essentially this version of
Loki is destroyed pretty quickly by
Odin's son and that's basically it again
it's a it's a cool concept that was one
of the big issues that this story had
there were a lot of really really cool
concepts that nobody really did anything
with and that was what was so so
irritating you know so disappointing
about it all but ultimately what we end
up doing is kind of following up with
with a few of these Avengers here and
there especially with James Rhodes who's
really not not necessarily totally
destroyed but whose suit is you know
essentially suffering at the moment as
well as a vision you know who looks like
yeast but he's in the process being
overtaken both of them managed to kind
of save the day James Rhodes chest chest
device is counted out of commission but
he still got his beams on his hands at
the same time we've kind of got Ultron
or at least you have a future vision
this corrupted version of vision with a
modern-day vision and you kind of get
this cool little moment where they sort
of improvise in the sense that like
vision and basically decreasing his
density so it becomes you know lighter
and lighter and then when the other
vision does the same thing James Rhodes
comes flying through and then vision
reestablishes his density and that
allows James Rose to kind of snatch her
up and get him out right so it's kind of
one step forward one step back and then
one step forward again you know kind of
slingshotting himself more or less but
one of the cool things you kind of get
out of this and this is something
exceedingly important to keep in mind is
the immoral nature of the Incredible
Hulk now al Ewing was the one who wrote
this story uh you know Ultron forever
this is the basis behind the immortal
Hulk story as it goes on right now
more comics and that was one of the
reasons why I wanted to cover this right
that the Incredible Hulk had kind of
been established over the years in
Marvel Comics that there was a sort of
immortal nature when it came to the Hulk
right the Hulk could never truly die or
if he could his durability was so
extreme it would take a person within it
with an equally extreme level of power
to defeat the Incredible Hulk
right so it would take somebody with
like reality warping abilities or
somebody you know so many astronomical
who could basically break the Hulk down
or kill the Hulk or do it in such a way
to where his body couldn't heal and
recover from the damage that was
sustained right he would just be dead
forever and so the results of this and
the way that al Ewing really kind of nip
this in the bud and brings in brings in
to Frank the notion of the Hulk being
truly immortal is with his decapitation
now I'm not overly familiar with bill
Mantlo or Peter David's run on the
Incredible Hulk and I haven't really
been able to find anything during their
runs from from the least poking around
doing some research that indicates that
like The Incredible Hulk could be
decapitated and banners head would grow
back in its place right I don't really
see anything to indicate that I could
have missed it there is a lot of history
to there the cover between those two
guys but the overall gist here is that
the Incredible Hulk with his head being
decapitated banners head kind of grows
out of his chest and we end up learning
this really interesting concept that
banner is really like physically inside
the Hulk that it's not really banner or
turning into the Hulk or at least it
kind of is to a degree but banners still
there and we wouldn't really expect it
to be that way you expect it to be one
of those things where the Incredible
Hulk head is the head of Bruce Banner
The Incredible hoax arms are the arms of
Bruce Banner they're just being mutated
and changed to become larger in size to
match the Incredible Hulk physique you
know to become the Incredible Hulk we
never really consider the possibility or
the idea that in the Incredible Hulk
physical body in there somewhere is
Bruce Banner right like we don't really
consider that I think that was the case
during the events of space Punisher but
in terms of this is a weird little bit
of a revelation it does allow the whole
continue on and it does allow Al viewing
to kind of prevent the paradox of the
fact the Incredible Hulk is the reason
why the Avengers came together and that
it The Incredible Hulk had been
destroyed before the Avengers came
together it would keep the Avengers from
existing you know kind of nips that
paradox in the bud and keeps that from
becoming a problem but well it's not the
biggest thing in the world the long and
short of this is that we kind of switch
over to the various Thor's that are here
now this is kind of cool because with
these three Thor's Thor from the future
the present and the past
this again was coming out of Jason
Aaron's run of Thor god of thunder which
of course came before this but kind of
taking these different points of of for
from different points in time and sort
of bringing them together now when they
end up confronting all-father ultron
this is one thing to understand this is
not Ultron just kind of taking the
ceremonial garb of Odin and that kind of
a thing
this is Ultron with all of Adam's power
Ultron has the odinforce now we're not
really given an explanation how he
killed Odin how he took over Odin or
anything like that weird assembly kind
of told that he basically managed to do
it now most likely what happened is that
Ultron killed Owen while he was in the
Odin sleep because I really kind of have
a difficult time believing that Ultron
could take on Odin and successfully
defeat him the big interesting takeaway
from this though is that Ultron with all
this power has not really been able to
figure out exactly why it is that he's
doing what he's doing right there are a
few things that we that we learn here
that Ultron being able to do what he's
done came by virtue of him having an
over metal body now which is essentially
the same material that makes up Thor's
hammer but all in all even with like the
odin vision like the god site the
ability to see everything they kind of
have this cosmic awareness bit Ultron
kind of looks inside of himself and
doesn't really understand the nature of
like what it means to want something he
doesn't understand why he's doing what
he's doing right what was the point of
conquering the earth
what comes next why wasn't revenge was
it just you know his programming a
desire he doesn't really grasp it and
because he doesn't really grasp but he
doesn't know the purpose behind any of
this now the reality is Ultron probably
did it because he's just a dick for the
problem is we don't really find out why
because what you end up getting is Jane
Foster who receives two of the hammers
and then basically uses them both to
kind of grip Ultron out of this current
reality right so basically wipe him from
existence now it is kind of a weird
thing because in Marvel they in a lot of
ways follow the rules of physics when it
comes to matter right that like matter
cannot be created nor destroyed it just
takes a different form matter that makes
up who you are as a human being doesn't
cease to exist when you die right you
basically end up becoming one with the
ground your body breaks down on the luck
Euler level and becomes part of the
world and that's kind of how matter
works you know at least from a from a
physics perspective and models sort of
follow that to a degree and so this idea
of Ultron really is just kind of him
being ripped out of reality or being
dispersed across cosmos but the overall
gist is that that Ultron is no longer
part of this situation and so what this
does is it really you know with with
this Ultron basically being removed it
allows the forces of James Rhodes it
allows vision and so on and so forth
just are kind of ripping air
enough to destroy the main hub of
control that Ultron had going on and
really make their exit once everything
is taken out the issue with this is that
once they're brought back by dr. doom
black widow figures out what exactly is
going on here that by looking around
inside their facility where initially
dr. doom was saying things like what we
can really find the backup hub and so
you know I'll see you guys back and
everything will be okay black widow
basically realizes they were in the
backup the entire time
this was all the scheme of Doctor Doom
the scheme of Doctor Doom was to
basically remove Ultron from the
landscape in an intern replace Ultron is
the one who was gonna conquer everything
now I know what kind of seems throwaway
but it truly is the nature of Doctor
Doom to do that the Doctor Doom always
tries to find a way to secure absolute
power and that's exactly what happened
here that's what's so cool about it is
that like it follows part and parcel
with Doctor Doom but here's the issue
and this is one of the big problems that
a lot of writers run into when it comes
to the character of Victor Von Doom he's
very hard to write effectively the only
two people that I've seen who have been
able to write Doctor Doom effectively
are Jonathan Hickman and Christopher
Cantwell at least in the modern era and
I mean he'll Stanley a Jack Kirby of
course they created him so of course
they could write him effectively but
honestly it's been a long long time
probably John burned too because it was
run on Fantastic Four but aside from
them Doctor Doom can be a very difficult
person to write you know he can be a
very difficult person to grasp so all
this is kind of in character you know it
is a little a little finicky the way it
goes down but it's Doctor Doom kind of
getting carried away with himself right
this idea that Doom kind of runs it all
right he controls everything now
initially he tries to send the Avengers
back in time he tries to sum the
Avengers back to their respective time
streams but this allows Thor really both
force a moment to kind of intervene and
to use their hammers and basically spin
the characters away from the time
platforms into a different location
right but what it does do is it allows
them to basically maintain their role
here to stay within this time stream and
still have the ability to correct
everything to defeat Doctor Doom and to
essentially free humanity from his
control right so it's a cool notion it's
a cool idea one of these stories where
you end up with the defeat of one
villain and then pick up with another
which I do always kind of enjoy okay so
we are picking back up with the
conclusion of Ultron forever and the
Ultron forever story again this is this
is this is the the kit and kaboodle the
whole end of it all with Doctor Doom
having seemingly taken over everything
right really kind of taken over where it
we're all Tron left off and again that's
one of the things that we hit at in the
last video is
for dr. doom this makes sense it's what
his character does either he outright
goes out there and tries to seize power
or he's an opportunist right he waits
until the right opportunity arises and
then he leaps on it and then tries to
seize control but whatever the case is
in this instance because of the fact
that Ultron himself has basically been
destroyed this left a kind of vacuum
there right like the Ultron robot
factories are still cranking away the
bio slaves you know former humans are
still there there's just nobody
controlling them and so dr. doom used
that moment to seize control of all
those systems and now dr. doom runs
everything and so with that being the
case he's come to the realization that
as it stands right now Asgard is the one
place whereby he's not really operating
or at least he he doesn't mean he has a
presence there
Ultron use that as a base of operations
but at the moment that's where the
heroes are located out that's where they
kind of teleported to and so the
discussion they sort of have there is
okay well let's break this down and
let's see you know how it is that we can
we can find some way to confront Doctor
Doom or some way to defeat Doctor Doom
now the other part of this is that
vision makes the case well let me talk
to them right now let me talk to dr.
doom and let's see if we can't figure
out what's going on but he's almost kind
of dismissed and a lot of people are
asking questions about whether or not
he's been compromised whether or not
he's used somebody they can actually
work for the team because remember this
is vision and a lot of these other
Avengers are currently out of time and
in their time stream they come from a
point where vision was created by Ultron
right he hasn't quite turned to become a
superhero yet and so because of that it
creates a situation where it's kinda
like okay kid we really trust these guys
and you know he really trusts vision and
even if he is a good guy now is there
some kind of subroutine that's allowing
you know Ultron or at least you know
that kind of it was activated when he
came here and now doctor dooms
controlling him is everything sorted out
right is he really a good guy those are
the kind of questions that people are
asking now the other part of this are
all of the all the Asgardians themselves
and when I say all the Asgardians I do
mean like all the Asgardians right like
hella SIF the Warriors three like all
the different trolls and so on and so
forth all these as Guardians that exist
out there are all trapped in what's kind
of referred to as a mirror prison and
the reason why it's called that is
because everything is the opposite right
so whenever you speak to them they hear
your words backwards right they hear it
all kind of garbled and jumbled and they
can't really make out what it is at your
sink and so that's one of the things
that kind of makes it impossible because
the other part of this is the mirror
dimension kind of you know begins to
sort of sack them of their power and of
their magic right so they don't really
have the ability to break free and
they're just constantly just sort of
wasting away until there really doesn't
seem to be anything
the problem with this is that the powers
of Thor and the shield of Captain
America haven't really been able to
break through this thing so there's no
real conceivable means Aveeno to
penetrate this prison of sorts until you
get to James Rhodes right and James
Rhodes kind of starts poking around and
doing a little bit of Investigation now
what this also leads to is Captain
America and the rest of the Avengers
showing up here and battling a whole
bunch of these Doombot ships right
attacking these ships basically
destroying the doombots that are
contained inside and kind of calling it
a day right and for the most part you
end up having it happen in America who
successfully come into yours a ship
fires on another ship that's sort of a
thing the problem here is that these are
carrier vessels right these are vessels
designed to carry a whole bunch of
doombots from one location to the next
they're really kind of battle cruisers
right they're big they're clunky they're
not like super lightweight and agile
ships and so because of that they kind
of move like a bus you know we're like a
semi truck and so at that point it's a
big clunky vessel and it's not really
doing her any good so as a result of
that you end up having all the Thor's
who throw their hammers to take out one
of the ships that starts firing on
Captain America's vessel and then of
course Captain America you know ends up
retaliating as well and and so on but if
I kind of goes away you would expect it
to but the important thing and really
one of the big takeaways that comes from
this is James Rhodes now an important
thing to understand here is James Rhodes
was never really like a poor man's Tony
Stark he was a substitute Tony Stark for
a time but James Rhodes was one of these
characters where he wasn't really like
that kind of genius that Tony Stark was
right it made sense what game Rhodes was
not designed to be the kind of genius of
Tony was he was designed to be a
different version of Iron Man right a
different take on the character insofar
that Tony Stark was there was a
prodigious engineer James Rose was
actually in a lot of ways a more
honorable man but also an exceedingly
good pilot he was a cunning pilot and a
great friend I know that because I
watched him burn alive on the lava flow
and it was it was messed up you know but
like he was a good friend that's what
friends do to friends we let them we
chop off their limbs and let them burn
alive in a lava flow obi-wan was a dick
like it's just that's just the way it is
anyway the benefit of James Rhodes comes
in a play that he's not like the kind of
engineer that Tony is he still is pretty
smart and one of the things that he
starts to pick up on here is that with
regards to the prison that light can
pass through right he can see them they
can see him which means that this
barrier is essentially transparent right
that's the way light works everything
that you see is there as a result of
light reflecting off of it right so if
this go
was designed in such a way to where he
couldn't see anybody on the other side
with and of course it is reflecting
light light cannot pass through but
because light can pass through this this
dome did it means other forms of light
like a high-intensity laser can pass
through as well and that was kind of the
failing of the various Thor's albeit
they didn't really have the wherewithal
to understand engineering on that scale
and this thing was built long after Tony
Stark and those the Reed Richards and
those guys have been destroyed so
there's really nobody there's like
inform them you know how to do that but
James Rhodes basically uses the repulsor
rays along with high intensity lasers
and basically you know along with the
help of beta ray bill on the other side
shatters the entire prison right which
frees all of the Asgardians who were
there it's a cool moment right it's a
cool little homage to James Rhodes that
even back then during the during the
early days when he was playing his role
as Iron Man for for a time that he was
an exceedingly capable character and so
what this does is it picks up with
vision jumping onboard the ship that's
currently being piloted by Captain
America and basically crashing the ship
of course he can adjust his density so
visions gonna be fine and the day kind
of seems to be saved right like all
these doombots that were showing up on
the doorstep of ask of Asgard have
basically been destroyed the perception
was the day was saved but as soon as
they turn around there's even more and
that really was the nature of Ultron and
that's really what you kind of ran into
when it came to any kind of
technological singularity and Marvel
Comics sentinels Ultron doombots
whatever the case is that what you ran
into was essentially a war of attrition
in the sense that like the heroes would
just be worn down by a constant
overwhelming force right that's why when
you had things like Days of Future past
you look at the list of heroes who died
in the Incredible Hulk is there and the
question is how could the Incredible
Hulk fall to sentinels he would tear
them apart
well because it's an overwhelming number
of signals and that overwhelming number
stays replenished right so maybe it was
something like 300 sentinels descended
on the Incredible Hulk and he was just
fighting for days and then eventually
the Incredible Hulk wore out and that's
when the Sentinels killed him that's
kind of how this this war of attrition
works for the Ultron robots is the exact
same way with the doombots it's the
exact same way the person or the side
with the most resources will take out
the side with the least resources right
it doesn't matter how badly you want
that battle it's just the way that it
works right it's just the way this goes
down and so because that you end up
having all these different superheroes
you know and it's kind of cool to see
right all the Asgardians all the
superheroes all these forces basically
going against all these doom bots and
holding their own quite readily right I
mean just holding their own able to able
to destroy a whole host of them but then
you start to
see small things right you see James
Rhodes talking about how his suit is
down to 15 percent there's a statement
of how long have we been doing this you
essentially have all these guys who have
been fighting you know for a long long
time and so ultimately you end up having
a reprieve that's called between Captain
America and and Black Widow and vision
and they start talking about how like
their numbers aren't really wearing thin
but their energy is they're starting to
be worn down this battle is gonna result
in them losing if it keeps on going on
for too long
and that's when vision chimes in and
says okay did it's time that you guys
trusted me right like I'm an Avenger I
promise you I'm an Avenger I'm one of
the good guys trust me here and
everything will be fine and so
ultimately they do what they end up
doing is teleporting directly to where
Doctor Doom is and that's when vision
starts talking to him and saying look
for the Avengers we're not surrendering
like we're not giving up it's just
important that we have we we sit down
and have a civilized conversation and
then he calls him Doombot and that's
what we end up learning here this was
never Doctor Doom in the first place
this was a Doombot
the entire time specifically it was a
character named Doombot now the question
is who is Dumba aren't in Marvel Comics
and 2013 as part of the second or third
wave of Marvel now you ended up getting
a Sam Humphreys line of comics called
Avengers AI now it only lasted 12 issues
but it was basically a an Avengers team
composed of artificially intelligent
beings right so like vision and so on
and so forth what you also had is you
had a new character introduced as
Doombot who is basically a Doombot who
kind of become autonomous or self-aware
now he may have predated Avengers AI and
in fact I think he actually did but this
is basically what this characters turned
into this is what this guy's evolved
into did following the the death of
Doctor Doom you know during the the rise
of Ultron and the destruction of all the
superheroes that this Doombot was the
last surviving version and so what
enough happening was a kind of protocol
was enacted where doctor dooms idea that
he must always live basically kind of
activated a subroutine that essentially
turned this Doombot into dr. doom right
convinced him that he's dr. doom and
then you get this kind of weird exchange
are you truly dr. doom because dr. doom
would not take instruction from anybody
like that he would never let another
dictate his actions right so it's like I
don't let anybody tell me what to do
even myself like that's kind of what
visions communicating here which is kind
of nonsensical doesn't really seem to
make any sense but ultimately it kind of
leads to to this doom Bob basically
saying okay you know I am my own person
right like I'm my own individual I am
absolutely control yes I was created by
a Victor Von Doom but I am NOT
Victor Von Doom I am my own person and
that kind of makes sense because Doombot
was a hero he seemingly just kind of
lost himself in the programming that was
that was activated following the death
of the original Doctor Doom and so what
you end up getting here is kind of a
stand down where doombots forces end up
backing down they end up stopping
everything comes to a head everything
sort of ends and what he does is he kind
of releases all of his doombots is what
was all of humanity to kind of go
forward and live their lives as they
would see fit now none of this really
ends up mattering in that and you know
in the end anyway because from what we
saw in Jonathan Hickman's Avengers the
New Avengers everybody on earth just
ends up getting turned into a giant
artificial intelligence anyway but the
result here is that people for the first
time in a few hundred years have now
achieved freedom and are able to kind of
go about and do their own thing and so
the ending of this story is a little bit
hokey you know is one of these things
where it's like you know it's kind of a
montage sort of situation and it's like
no matter what happens you know if
anybody ever sends out the call the
Avengers will always assemble you know
there will always be the Avengers and
and they're like they're waving at us
the Avengers are waving to us say hi
everyone but would that be said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
to make sure you hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you